how you people and a proven this is the
Rubin report
by two guys with great names Alonso Duralde Max Lugavere
award-winning names on the show this
week let's get right to it
hillary clinton have you heard about
this lady her husband was the former
governor of arkansas he became president
then she became a senator from New York
then she became Secretary of State
national wrote a book called hard
choices and
she was interviewed by Diane Sawyer on
ABC news
and had some interesting things to say
about the clintons wife post
presidency it has been reported you've
made five million
making speeches the president made more
than 100 million dollars well
you if if you you have no reason to
remember but we came out at the white
house
not only dead broke but in dept we had
no money when we got there
and we struggle to you know piece
together the resources for
mortgages for houses for childhood
education
you know it was not easy they had no
money when they got there I didn't know
that and then
not only dead broke but in get when they
left
at max we're watching this before we
start a new you picked up on
an interesting added s add yeah I
mention makes it sound like her life was
really hard having multiple houses
yeah it was poor whole I can't believe
that they left a while
is a is that true were actually
according to open secret in 2000 when
the Clintons left the white house they
did network at -10 million dollars but
you could only get to a net worth at -10
in doubt if you add access
two tons of money before that so for her
to imply that somehow they were dead
broke or really in debt knowing how much
money
with about to come in 100 million bucks
and play
feel like there are there are levels
above insanely recchia okay and
more Bri will probably never be in this
boat but I
and get where he's coming from no-no
okay you're right through it all
possible but I no I mean I i mean i
think
yet on there's a will there's a little
bit disingenuous disingenuousness going
on here
but at the same time yet they had to pay
a lot a legal fees for all that
whitewater crap in all the other sort of
football should accusations got her loom
over the course of the years
their daughter with their school yes
they have multiple houses I'm not
no one is thinking that these people or
you know get a good one food stamps or
G under said the idea genuine poverty
but
I don't begrudge them the ability to
make money making speeches i mean
I you know I grew what we'll get to that
part I don't think anyone regret is them
the chance
that to make money by the way bill
clinton as for president get the
you know yearly the soured this typing
up like a hundred twenty thousand
which is still more than most people
make on top about the money for speeches
and all that
the but there are two let's talk about
then what happened after so then
Hillary time do this first we had to pay
off our debts
which was you know you had to admit
double the money because I've obviously
taxes and pay off the debts and
guest houses and take care of family
members but do you think americans can
understand five times
the median income in this country for
months
speech well let me put it this way I
thought
making speeches for money was a much
better thing than getting connected with
any
one group or company as so many people
who leave public life do
outcome so much better than everyone
else in public life because not good not
only did
should take money from one giant
companies take money pretty much
from everybody should take a lot of
money from Goldman Sachs defender go
alright well how many seconds before
Eric Cantor becomes a lobbyist or II
depending on how much overall thing door
is for these people to go back
and like she'll for you know big
armament or performer wherever else so I
you know I will please give the point I
do you expect you you get that money
retreat is your lease
singing for your supper at the great
supper obviously but yeah
you're not in anybody's pocket you know
with so many former politicians are II
look I'm OK think she did anyone when
she takes five hundred thousand pretty
speeches to
uncorked after I'm nothing the clintons
are pure and perfect or or anything else
but I'm just saying
I think we're kinda hop piling on four a
relatively non gross wave being a former
politician
also you know based on what other people
were doing yeah I've seen clinton speak
on behalf of global
Clinton Global Initiative and I you know
i'm always you know completely inspired
by
by him in the work that they're doing in
I don't begrudge them anything yeah but
this out to me this is about a great
because I agree with you they have to
make money somehow people pay them for
the speeches that's fine I was
you know we are a capitalistic society
it's more the idea that she's framing it
as if they struggled
which it so I do think they'd ever not
been able to get
since he's been president or even
probably a little bit before the you
think there's
anything they've ever wanted that they
haven't been able to get have a
ever not been able to go to a restaurant
but they wanted to go to or buy a car
that they wanted or or anything
go with the struggle it's not the writer
but maybe the question here's why is
dying for your framing at like
oh how dare you make this much money or
go ask George W Bush question go ask
you know any former senator who is now
you know showing from Northrop Grumman
that question wanna know why
when Hillary it's like when hillary does
it certainly is the worst thing ever
well I totally hear that and listen I
would give dick cheney as much shit for
you know helping Halliburton get
contracts which I'm in the back
sorry I'm just giving them all equality
the letter thoroughly all about there
might be a battle I nominate from The
Dark Knight Rises we're talking about
superhero movies over and I didn't even
go broke like the rest of us
yeah I don't know how much could I ever
getting ten million dollars that would
be birch really impossible
this is bliss is a one-percent lemme
style bankruptcy
yeah which is that there's somebody is
willing to loan you 10 million and
you're able to pay back a member
yeah a pretty good said around white why
is it that people are so afraid of being
proud of success because I think that
that goes to what you're saying about
Diane Sawyer's question
there is this this idea that everyone
has to be struggling all the time I'll
people who are running for president me
to come off as
relate a bull and you know well singer
is running for Prime II
you know I hear big things I don't know
but you know I I think
she's this is clearly part of the near
the above you know just plain folks
which
they have work to a certain extent or
other ever since leaving arkansas
yeah what do we do you think we had this
like weird implicit shame about success
in this country
arm you know I if we do it's sad
you know I I like to think that we
should you know be proud people hold
people's examples on to become
successful for
noble causes you know and I think it's
important to see them as reliable but I
think that there there
necessity for that has passed you know
that's what got him into office
yeah arm way I mean I you know again I i
think that
that the success that they've had post
post presidency i think is warranted
into alright well I think what we learn
here is that I will not be voting for
Hillary I think a lot though will be
voting for NOAA will
maybe I rode with a ready answer and Max
possibly St a possibility a probable
okay all right let's move on
a computer by the name a new gene
because what other name would a computer
have
path deterring test which basically
means
it simulated humored human conversation
as a 13-year-old boy a we've got a
little more info Korea
at deterring test which test artificial
intelligence with introduced by Alan
Turing
in 1950 he predicted the computer is one
day be able to be programmed to acquire
abilities rivaling
human intelligence were pretty much
right there a person engages in a
text-based conversation with another
person and a computer
and must determine which is which if
they're unable to do so the computer is
deemed
to a path it requires 30 percent have
human interrogators
to be duped during five-minute keyboard
conversations I think we've all
or get into the specific to that we've
all had these experiences with these
computers like if you go I'm
to like time-warner check to try to find
out
and you can you literally can't tell if
you're talking to so
this surprise you that this test %uh
been have what I have been really weird
but I agree with this online is that
this is a hoax
that this guy I would look at that okay
you have a regular I
know yet this guy at Reading University
the pearly infamous for these are things
I think he claimed to be the first human
to be infected with the computer viruses
and they're apparently a lot of people
who undergo a bleak kinda
reporting this story but it's not true
218 it seems like it half true that
apparently this did
it'd actually path but there's some
questions about his
methodology there was a really great so
I don't get to focus on that just more
the brought sorta broader idea by the
way
real quick about Allen turning he was
persecuted for homosexuality
and after he was convicted in 1952 I
he with chemically castrated little
little
something there and after winning the
World War Two thanks very much and I
know he's one of the great game martyrs
of history and actions we movie about
him
starring Benedict Cumberbatch coming out
this year really okay hopefully at that
and I think a stamp will get him is do I
think but yeah no
outpouring is a what is it that you're a
really smart gay people because the guy
from a beautiful mind also
although the movie made it through my
yeah it's great I was or wasn't he a
author
I i weird you're weird for gay guys are
good with numbers our anger
okay I took going back to this without
getting too much into the
to the specific to the desk that a
little unclear as yet I whether about
taking over
as I somehow after the show every week
with interesting that recurs will
particular this would happen by 2029 and
yes obviously a lot sooner than that but
I wrong
I think that well no I mean I you know
that guy does is the upgrade years of
his bro I thought you meant Criswell
that but the truth is the guy you know
her and when I do not expect her
all TVs like eight okay nevermind while
he's like the head injuries are okay
then you probably don't know if the IRA
car had ok where are we going to lie I
think we need to redefine how we
how we define artificial intelligence
you know I mean obviously this is a test
that was devised in nineteen fifties so
what others ideas you know whenever they
try to predict the future in the fifties
and
ends up looking ludicrous like that well
what on I well yeah arm
but you know I think it's somewhat
interesting is that
this device what they told the pat the
jury panel that it was a 13-year-old boy
English was not his first language
automatically Arabia great
yet and and so I don't think it's a
surprise that
he won you know I and but it was hardly
a supercomputer was an algorithm that
was designed to chat bot and by the way
this is the first time that happened
rabbi in 2011 call the clever bother did
this in
India so again when to the robots take
over I wanted
my I wanted gay I think it's
neck-and-neck do the robot takeover
before or after we render the earth
uninhabitable
you I am at you're gonna be a great time
and yeah
that I think you know to do who's gonna
get their purse I don't know yeah I
do you guys think that maybe somebody is
why I always talk about it as if the
robot retailer we getting a Google cars
last week they won't even have steering
wheel
so you'll be trapped in your car to be
were to hack into them and they were all
walking around with these devices so
they can watch is Elizabeth mother
a.m. I just totally alarm is on it and
that being said I still do all this
stuff and I love it I think it's so cool
and I love all the movies about it
but is that is purely alarmist that mean
I think I think it's great i think the
idea of having driverless cars
could potentially save us from having
water accidents I mean there's a huge
accident in the news over the weekend
about a
truck driver who had slept for 24 hours
and cause a huge pile up knowing right
to your door your
right Obama you know Google is now
they're offering like
you know cloud storage for autism
research which is supposed to be amazing
so I'm
I'm definitely like bullish on the
future I think that like technology has
amazing things to offer and
you know it's it's it just gets sorted
out a hand when the media take something
that's not really a story in Bend
you know blows at a proportionally they
did with this supercomputer but I do
think that at the end of the day
we're heading in the right direction yet
do you agree with his yeah
you know I I wish Google would stop
censoring the Chinese internet but they
are obviously you may be making a lot of
cool things happen and I'm not I i don't
worry so much about
what we're what were upset rendering the
technology as much as low I'm not
kidding I really wonder if
if it's kind it's going to take over if
they're gonna beat us to destroying the
ozone layer and you know like
making another ice caps melt right or as
in what happens in the Terminator movies
and and in like Wile E that they'll have
the flavor us
because we're the ones that are
destroying the Earth and it'll be
against their
written orders their laws and then
they'll have to turn on a
I for one welcome our new robot
overlords I don't know there you go
all right let's move on this is wild a
company outta oklahoma is producing for
one thousand dollars
bulletproof blankets poor kid
use in schools because the thing about a
school shooting the course we had
another one yesterday just never stop
there was a one week before
we've got some images a blanket 3i
thousand bucks he can protect against
ninety percent of the weapons that have
been used
in school shootings in the United States
there were 13 school shootings in the US
the first six weeks
up 2014 we're now for months path that
I am so I guess first
is this just inevitable that every kid
is gonna be going to school
with the a bullet-proof blanket I don't
even have words for how appalling the
idea that
we now have to travel or our kids
blankets in the schools because
god forbid we do any tiny tiny thing
about guns in this country
in said no we all have to be walk around
with bulletproof vests
that's the answer I i cant even I mean I
definitely think they're
a good idea you know i mean the there'd
attempting to solve
there's something to put out the smoke
rather than put out the fire
ran for like a better X expression by
Tom because it doesn't look like gun
reform is happening anytime soon in this
country and people are actually dying
you know Minister another shooting
that occurred you know yesterday arm I
think that to have those in school to be
a
a positive thing and the animal print
doors but they've been experiment my
is it all a little bit absurd a fake
protection because
the idea that the kid would be you know
with when this would happen I assume
they don't keep them on them all the
time or probably even under their desks
that
you know you mean by the time you were
able to get it out of the closet or
something that the bathtub is already
have
so I this is just sorta just Arrowhead
is it bakery for the pairing emma is it
that telling kids oh by the way you
could get shot at any moment
so do keep this handy enos so that's the
part that I think the most intriguing do
you think that would be that
the real their part is the conditioning
that all these kids are gonna grow up
thinking that this is just
really part of the way like this even
though I i get is at some level but all
I i think that you have to adapt to the
times like I went to highschool
are elementary school in manhattan and
we are remember growing up we had drills
where we have to get into the deaths in
case there was a
like a nuclear attack or something like
that drop in the fifties
no there isn't doing enough for you
otherwise I remember there was
you have to get on the desks and brace
yourself for some kind of like
attack or something like that yeah to as
like in New York and obviously I don't
think that that a
applies today but today we have this
very real and present
you know dangerous school shootings
something i read online this week that
was interesting was that one of the
great semantic
tour you know twists over everything
years is that we keep calling these
shootings
and nobody ever calls them murderers
then if we called the murders maybe we
were taken more seriously but
shootings different things more
innocuous than that and that allowed the
kinda
process this on a daily basis that is
constantly happening
and we are more appalled by the yeah is
that the other scary part here is that
so when I saw the shooting yesterday
I remember where was where was it
because this happens constantly who are
already know the right was an organ and
I guess the shooter and one other
the guy in North Hollywood couple days
ago right and then what what was one
last week the
last week was getting Santa Barbara
right or was that we can have a
um but i think is happening in this go
to the conditioning part
is what I see on Twitter there's a
shooting now it doesn't even phase me
for a split second or you know to me to
my co another one make
and that to me is the scary parts are we
just becoming
the warrior yeah I mean are we just
becoming more and more
okay with it so I so this is something
these by get the benefits
not real protection I saw your flakes
are completely exposed on those things
you know yeah I mean if the guy wants
the day
you get what you needed 200 medley or
something like a big turtle show
you should get into that is I wouldn't
do anything to do with I
we get a boner I mean save one life you
know I answer
that there is a great initiative yeah
arm so if we can change gun laws which
it seems like
week can't seem to do since we couldn't
get anything passed after a new town in
Syria
I am if we can't do that then what what
should we beat actually tacking meant to
help more
because it seems to me there's a lot as
a there's a lot to do with mental health
and prescription drugs only one shot
ahead said yesterday though with their
withers mentally hell
mentally ill people all over the world
and there are violent video games
all over the world and there are
frustrated single guys all over the
world
this is the country where all those
people get gotten better
yeah exactly to yes any video game
called by later they say every time I be
an Italian plumber eating my cum
dripping a turtle
I am really matter other than as they
really do with about the video game okay
let's move on
is the American dream crumbling I
a new poll says that nearly six out of
10 people
say the American Dream is now impossible
to achieve
in this country the support from CNN
money's American Dream poll
conducted by Orca international to young
adults aged 18 to 34 well not even in
that group anywhere that if they're
are most likely appeal the dream is
unattainable with sixty-three percent
think it impossible that is incredibly
depressing
at 53 percent up all-american said most
children in the US won't be better off
than their parents and sixty-seven
percent of Americans say they have not
achieve the American dream
I remember when I was in my attempt a
greater 11th grade
I I took a class II things like a social
studies ago of future spacecraft
and the teacher saying that you guys are
gonna be the first generation that
in america that's going to be worse off
their parents and I really like that
like
hit me waco shaped like this and now
it's at that was
twenty years ago and now it's actually
happening how disturbing is this I mean
it as a member a minute generation that
they were good god I think I have a very
very long I get you a second
yeah my retirement my thing I think the
idea of the American Dream has
definitely evolved you know and I think
it's a lot different for young people
today
you know I think if anything we are the
access generation access means
more toss and I think it should then
ownership Kevin Kelly is a
phenomenal author talks a lot about you
know technology and features and stuff
so that access is better than ownership
I believe that you know we live in the
age who were you know it's buchanan over
today
with greater ease than it is owning a
freakin car on you can air BnB
you know places all around the world
rather than owning a house I think that
some
it's just a different world we live in
you know like it's better to have access
to things and i own stock right and
I and so I'm perfectly okay with that
you know well
a little a little hope of a depressing
study what do you think I i mean
obviously the American Dream is for a
vague in amorphous and and you know it
it is what you think it is
I but as far as the idea of people not
thinking they are going to do better
than their parents i mean that is
sadly the reality and I think that all
kind of stems from
everything since ronald reagan basically
has been about the dismantling of the
20th century
are the dismantling I love you know
labor unions the dismantling ove
voting right the dismantling up
everything that was
making us a more perfect union and that
was I
to providing you education for people
and and you know the
the this was the country that that
ghetto went to the moon rock all the
stuff that we accomplished but when we
got past
the Gilded Age we're now back to the
Gilded Age we're now back to the
you know the .1 percent and then the
rest of us
yeah an I think and and and that is that
the point one percent by weight cuz it's
not the one person who does not know
many times the one presented
make somewhere around four hundred
thousand dollars which obviously is
great I don't make anywhere near that
but those are the people that are really
the in that top echelon 33 mean tiny
amount of people who control the
massive amounts of well the tax break
they have been given
by taking their money offshore by taking
jobs offshore
by not reinvesting in their companies I
you know in the third is hoarding of
somewhere
that is this is the reagan effect this
is the country we live in now
this is the country where aware what was
once the land of opportunity and is now
not so much I like this we had hoped her
right now we have no hope
why I think that as a generation we
shinri you know every generation should
reassess what it means to do
good you know like are we happy robbery
is schorr
are we safer you know are we to refuel
you know more sort of creatively express
so its own that though then seemed like
the scary part to me because the
sixty-three percent are saying that that
Green's impossible even though
the hopi parts that you gave it a pretty
good I
even though those exist these people
still don't think
that whatever the idea of the dream is a
happiness that the part i think is
interesting here maybe happiness is
is unattainable I don't know if that
study is as you know it was questioned
you know more deals whether or not they
have the right not to believe that the
dream is impossible whatever you think
the dream is if you're saying it
impossible things like it might affect
your
happiness right yeah I know whether it
was an index I have objective fingering
I guess I think that we have the tools
to be happier are
their parents you know arm or maybe not
yeah obviously don't know no I mean I I
think you're right it is what it is very
subjective
I don't think you know if the American
Dream used to be about I don't know
owning a home in the suburbs clearly
that's not
as much the goal anymore inni you know I
agree with you that the that we were
moving away from
the sort of idea I love you know there
was a possessions are about
you know the sort of the me know marked
lines in the sand yet to accomplish 22
be a successor to achieve the dream but
as for just the basic
love are you know my parents were
immigrants to this country and they want
their kids have more opportunities they
would have had
if they'd stayed in Spain and I think
that parents want their kids to do
better and now we're looking at
kids realize you that's not going to
happen and that's kinda demoralized yeah
that is a scary thought I want to spin
this positively before we go back to me
one final thought that's gonna make
everyone feel really good about the
futures in my drawer birthday a couple
buzzword in a rather you
a oculus rift I'll be pretty well so you
believe in a virtual
yeah it or that in a virtual happy world
okay very good
let's move on to i saw this a commercial
online to the YouTube
only commercial or advertisement or
promo that coca-cola dade
sort of explaining how you would burn
off calories by drinking one can
up their delicious soda let's take a
look
no
we actually spice that so you can get
the poor thing there but the poor thing
is I need you
but basically they're trying to make it
seem like this fun cool being
having to burn off the calories that it
takes 23 minutes of exercise if you're
140 pounds for one little 12 and a can
of coke
I do something very perverse about this
season everyone's a group that is where
I live at for pork
and it was it was all people exercising
really working hard like
I do all this so that I can eat pork you
know exactly who had accepted really
good yeah
parity is now become the real thing and
and this ad is so
well per sold any open should sue for
the slight tweak pee-wee's big adventure
the MPI
I but also the idea that you know
yes here you can leave your bike for 20
minutes you're in you're entitled to a
coke despite the fact that
a coke has more sugar than the other
than the average adult should consume an
entire day
right poison yeah I mean that shit is
the you know and the course it's high
fructose corn syrup
we don't even get the actual sugar yet
to go to Mexico right and even barely
afford to go hyper goes out with her
like it
but the whole calorie thing being the
end on Bo's
I think pretty much been established as
kind of a myth have dieting not that I
clearly have a weight loss
girl but you know i think thats very
much oversimplifying the big yellow this
ad
credit brings up a good risk you know
get outta work out then get a bit slow
down or should we head over before we
get too deep into the Kali part out what
my me doesn't it
the ideal what they're doing here seem
really quite what I mean the marketing
tactics that these
you know junk food companies you no use
to me
is completely pervasive ended drives me
crazy did you guys read that study that
came out last week about how
diet soda you know help people lose
weight which was actually a study funded
by the American
their shot I'm shot its graphic is most
certainly say that actually makes you
crave sugar and that is you know
according to convert to the benzene your
body and I don't think I already did not
order a ton
%uh awful food and then they get a diet
to rethink matter of setting
yeah I anybody's interested in this
topic should see my handler David movie
fed up with a documentary meters out all
about this how it's not just you know a
collar reimburses a color
how these you know by drinking a can of
soda it actually spike your insulin it
did it prevents you from feeling
satiated you know so makes you hungrier
and it's a it's a major player in the
obesity epidemic
cook even coca-cola's watered brand the
funny
has salt NS yeah
said all the way both of -ism that
should think you could stay thirsty
it's insane okay until then what is coke
doing here what it what are they
really what are the Martin people saying
like they're just saying we know the
people are more health-conscious
so we're gonna make it seem bon you know
when using this actual machine for
exercise
I do cardio not fun and actually it's
born other be doing more
its force me to cut them is that in my
diet may have that rube goldberg thing
at the gym I might consider going to
what you know but there's a big giant
hand gonna give me a coke at the end I
might you know
I want that for Pee wee Herman thing we
do that hoping to get the look in your
theory absolutely here with a coke n
roll down all the things got pushed in
your face when you open a bottle
problem that is a good point I guess
interposition coke is like a reward like
there's no better reward for exercise
you know
her then a coke bring a coke which
regularly better award for exercise been
doing something that reverses although
I've to a factor and is not quench your
thirst at all after the exertion you've
just gone through I have a marriage
properties
yet by the way call a little more info
on the the average
soda drinker consumes about 2.6 glasses
each day
so this was 2.6 cans of coke that would
mean about an hour upcycling
so this stuff is just not good for you
and but we do all the stories everyone
then attacked me and says
you know we should have our indulgences
attack anything
yes I drink some other stuff too but we
should be more aware
up what's going on hiatus sometimes food
as they say on Sesame Street you know it
%uh sometimes rude you know if I
if you have like a coke. every couple
weeks you know it's not going to be the
worst thing in the world for you
but yet 2.6 a day that and say so. final
thought that we could cook any credit
then
for all her own and they are they're
just be a purely you know I'm just tryna
played Devils I does definitely happen
again yeah
the signs the least offensive product on
the market but even if tap water and/or
overpaying for
yeah that's all that's all what I want
all the cup water
I final topic I half americans believe
in conspiracy theories I love
this story reason think that study
suggests that around 50 percent American
subscribe to at least one conspiracy
theory
this info is coming from NPR's social
science corresponded
shank are bend and TAM director at that
rate you guys are definitely NPR people:
no I think I think I was closed from
NPR's morning addition
let looking to find a good day so
nineteen percent of Americans believe
the US
government was behind the 9/11 attack
that seems incredibly high to me so the
fact that in fact
a 25 percent believe the recent
financial crisis
was caused by a smoke a bow on Wall
Street bankers who
and here's a good one 11 percent believe
the government is mandating the switched
to compact fluorescent light bulbs
because the white bold make people
obedient
an easy to control now I will play the
rational person here for one second
Carl Sagan said the extraordinary claims
require extraordinary evidence that's
generally how I think about these things
I although I probably I have no problem
with aliens im pretty sure aliens have
been here and I'm integrating at
arm the nineteen percent on 9/11 seems
really high to me
what you think although I don't like
YouTube commenters that probably very
well
I was going to remain yeah I do I
believe that numbered or do I think that
do they just seem high that that one out
of five Americans would would believe
that it was
that the guy I like when you think about
it rationally would actually seems low
and you think that
you know in a in a moment sheer panic
and helplessness you know
in in times like that the party to bring
you make the love that's the fear center
goes into or
it's in the brain and analytical
overdrive her and it leads to us for
coming up with these narratives and help
us better explain the circumstances
would resist
so out of the ordinary and so you know
so fearful and
I think that work fence mechanism that
in a way in a country where the same
people believe what they hear on Fox
News
nothing surprising I bring to you though
I mean think about conspiracy theories
is that
I you know be it's not like the
government is so
fewer that we can't ever believe that
anybody
you know they we didn't put smallpox in
blankets and give it to the native
americans i mean
it's not like word that the US
government is incapable love shenanigans
so its not burn the hardest thing to
believe that americans are happening in
America jumper collection at a good with
that night
I mean we do something dies a lot of
drugs that are making people you know
peace in this country and so
you know it corn corn corn growers why
there why the government wants makes it
is making it difficult for you know
Tesla to sell cars because the oil
companies are paying them to do it you
know
so why not then think that maybe the CIA
decided to kill John F Kennedy or
something i mean you know
okay said so let's talk about the floor
of my building cuz I think that was the
meeting to 11 percent saying that these
new government mandated
libeled the light is actually a way of
controlling you
they had what do you think therefore I
like to be a big help for us that lie to
my high school and nobody was being
controlled so I am NOT buying now on
that that that to me seems like a
fluoride in the water kind of right you
know
John Birdsall working as I don't know
the real you any research from a4a
I don't know I mean I i can only you
know told you know love my personal
experience under floor might have always
felt like a little more anxious
relied on yeah really a babysit look
weird they're not flattering those for
us
Laura interesting so by were feel weird
what do you mean by that
well i just i you know it's it's and the
lighting is never good summer
you know comfortable on you know as a
kid I never really liked being
under that sort of false life Ronald
artificial
yet whether that we're going home there
there's a there's also an audible
component to a person like that and I
don't know yeah I have like a home that
no
I think that people like tape hiss
almost you know it's got this like
really sorta
you know subtle effect on your
subconscious but why did I mean to its a
pretty crazy
idea that the government will be trying
to clear all that though is that the
beauty of conspiracy theories you don't
have to prove any of them so it's like
that
which one to believe in something like
the alien stuff obviously have no proof
I vote but it also it also fueled good
to think that you're you know in a bit
to pack up she put your to walk but her
idea you're not going follow the
track do you guys have one that you
subscribe to a guess maybe the Dayak a
thing for your
know it fighter but the CIA I I feel
like there's more the JFK
thing then we're being told that but I
don't know what it is
I haven't done the research with and I
saw the oliver stone movie many times I
ID again
a down were already there I'm not into
conspiracy theories
a not right now I think nothin now
alright but we know for a fact the bush
wanted to invade Iraq
the second he entered office and that
actually that's not a concern that it
appears that the thing that we know now
also that without the kind of thing that
makes conspiracy theory believable
look it up ending a conspiracy theory
segment with the fact that is founded
alonzo Mac thank you guys their twitter
is a write down below
check them out doing all the crazy stuff
that they're doing you're gonna new
a brain think that we're giving yeah I i
cant say much about it but yeah it's
gonna be cool
but the frame and yet out there I mean
higher back better what you guys with
the rector